[Music]
in the animal kingdom intelligence has
evolved in many different ways in many
different creatures
we often think of our fellow primates at
the top of the intelligence list with
their ability to use tools like sticks
and rocks to access food and with their
ability to recognize themselves in the
mirror
orcas too are among the most intelligent
with their unique language skills and
orchestrated hunting techniques
and anyone with a dog is constantly
surprised at complex feats of social
intelligence and emotional sensitivity
intelligence seems to thrive in animals
like this
mammals often carnivorous ones that live
in tight social groups but if we survey
the world of animals one of the smartest
is one that is perhaps unexpected an
animal that isn't a mammal at all but a
bird crows
or more generally corvids corvids are
mischievous playful and extremely
intelligent
they use tools to forage and to solve
complex problems
they even drop nuts on a road for cars
to crack and then pick them up with the
safety of pedestrian lights
they can also recognize faces and can
hold a grudge against someone who is
rude to them for several years
they can mimic sounds that they hear and
scientists have found that their problem
solving skills rival that of a
seven-year-old human
how is it that crows are so profoundly
intelligent and how is it that we even
measure their intelligence in the first
place
is bird intelligence wired in the same
way as mammal intelligence or is it
something different altogether
the corvid family is also known as the
crow family and includes crows jays
ravens rooks and magpies
the level of intelligence varies between
the species but scientists have found
that the new caledonian crow is the most
intelligent
there to corvids what we are to the rest
of the primates in 2014 the crows were
presented with various tubes filled with
water with a treat floating on top which
they couldn't quite reach
in one trial when presented with a treat
inside a tube of water and a treat
sitting on top of sand the crows knew to
drop rocks into the water-filled tube to
raise the water level to reach the treat
and ignored the tube with sand
in the next trial when presented with a
single tube of water and objects with
various densities the crows knew to
select the sinking objects rather than
the floating ones to reach the treat
when presented with two tubes of
differing water levels the crows knew to
drop objects in the tube with the higher
water level to reach the treat faster
these trials demonstrated the crow's
abilities in both problem solving and
tool use and the authors believe that
their skill level at deciphering and
completing these tasks is similar to
five to seven year old children
however in two more challenging tasks
the crows didn't perform as well
one required understanding the
difference in a wide tube versus a
narrow tube and another was a
counter-intuitive task where the tube
with the reward was connected to another
tube via a hidden u-bend
the crows didn't fully grasp these
setups but in comparison during tests
with human children
only kids around eight years old were
able to consistently solve such tests
and in addition to using tools new
caledonian crows can build tools and not
just simple ones but ones with multiple
parts
when given objects that were too short
to retrieve food from a puzzle box the
crows combined elements by inserting one
stick into the hollowed opening of
another
to make a tool long enough to reach the
food
one crow even made three and four part
tools
compound tool construction like this has
only been observed outside humans in a
few captive great apes
it's usually only associated with human
intelligence
and in addition to this we now think
crows might be better than we ever could
have imagined at making plans for the
future the ability to take actions now
that will give a benefit later is not
something that most animals are good at
delayed gratification and planning are
high order skills
human children can't do this and neither
can many of the adults that i know
it requires our memory of the past and
foresight for future events
can crows of all animals really possess
this ability
in a study published in 2020 new
caledonian crows were first shown one of
three puzzle boxes that they already
knew how to open
each requiring a specific tool
they were then removed from the test
area for five minutes before being
presented with five different objects
one tool for each of the boxes and two
distraction objects
after selecting an object and waiting 10
minutes they were allowed back into the
test area
the researchers discovered that not only
did the birds choose the correct tool
that would open the corresponding puzzle
box but they would remember to bring the
tool with them into the test area
in another study researchers presented
the birds with a locked box with a treat
in a similar manner
but this time the birds were then
presented with an assortment of items
including the correct tool a few
distractor tools and an immediate food
reward
but one that was less appealing than the
one in the locked box
and most of the time the birds took the
risk and delayed their gratification
kept the correct tool and later opened
the box with the better treat
this might seem easy to us but it isn't
only once human children reach 5 years
old does this ability arise
and even then it doesn't in all of them
for some it takes a few more years
these mental skills certainly set crows
apart from other animals with their
actions and abilities more in line with
the smartest of the primates
how does this bird give the most
intelligent primates a run for their
money
why does a bird need to be this smart
even though crows may have a similar
intelligence to many primates bird
brains and primate brains are not at all
the same
birds and mammals split on the
evolutionary tree 320 million years ago
and since then their brains have become
quite distinct from one another making
scientists question exactly why corvids
are so smart
in vertebrates the pallium is the gray
and white matter that covers the brain
before the evolutionary split both birds
and mammals evolved a large pallium but
after their lineages split the mammalian
pallium evolved into a layered structure
known as the cerebral cortex
this is the most complex structure of
the mammalian brain
each layer contains nerve fibers running
horizontally and vertically that process
and transmit information
here is where many important functions
take place
including learning memory sensory
perception and conceptual thinking
birds don't have a cerebral cortex
but a study published in 2020 found that
the fibers in circuitry in the bird
pallium are organized very similarly to
a mammalian neocortex
with fibers running both horizontally
and vertically
the authors believe this explains where
bird intelligence comes from
another reason why birds were initially
thought to be incapable of this level of
intelligence was due to the small size
of their brains
but it's not the absolute size of an
animal's brain that matters but the
brain to body ratio
crows tend to have big brains compared
to their body size
in mammals the bigger brained
individuals are humans and dolphins in
birds it's parrots and crows
however as scientists understanding of
the brain grew they discovered it wasn't
just size that mattered or even brain
size relative to body size
a big proponent of an animal's
intelligence is the density of neurons
this is because having tightly packed
neurons leads to better communication
between them
and it turns out that certain bird
species have very densely packed neurons
in a 2016 study researchers measured the
number of neurons in various bird and
primate species they found that some
birds like corvids have twice as many
neurons as primates with similar sized
brains with numbers closer to that of
larger primates
while these findings tell us how crows
are so smart the question remains as to
why
plenty of bird species thrive with fewer
neurons and weaker mental abilities so
why did crows evolve this way
one theory is that it has to do with the
way they are raised
unlike other species corvids spend more
time with their parents
new caledonian crows are fed by their
parents for up to two years
during this time they have ample access
to role models who are making and using
tools and have the opportunity to use
these tools themselves
this extended parenting time allows
skills to be transmitted vertically
meaning from parent to offspring
the family groups of many species of
crow can be very tight with young crows
even helping to defend their parents new
nest of babies
however beyond tight family groups
adults of many species of corvids don't
lead particularly social lives
new caledonian crows mate for life but
otherwise don't really interact with
other adults
other species of corvid will often
forage and roost in large groups or work
together to mob a predator
but there isn't a social hierarchy or
complex social bonds in these settings
this seems to go against one leading
theory of intelligence called the social
intelligence hypothesis
chimpanzees for example live in large
and complex social groups where they
have to interact with others outside
their immediate family and keep tabs on
many relationships
it's a constant game of politics
dogs wolves and even orcas have to deal
with a great amount of social complexity
and this social intelligence needs a lot
of brain power
if adults of many of the smartest
corvids don't live in complex social
groups
why would a similar intelligence have
evolved
adult corvids may rarely live in wide
social groups but often juveniles do
before pairing up with a mating partner
during their teenage years some species
of corvids live in larger flocks aptly
called juvenile gangs
and these gangs work exactly like they
sound a bunch of teenagers hang out and
bully each other and fight in these
angsty years corvids like ravens for
example form the many relationships that
they have to keep tabs on
and intriguingly corvids may need social
intelligence to interact with other
species
outside of yellowstone national park
certain ravens have been seen
interacting with wolves especially wolf
pups
the animals have been seen playing tug
of war and the ravens tease and entice
the puppies to jump and grab sticks
sometimes the ravens will even pull the
wolves tails
by all accounts it looks like the
animals are playing
some scientists think that individual
ravens may even develop special bonds
with individual wolves within a pack
this relationship building may help the
ravens more readily scavenge the wolves
kills
this propensity to interact with other
species has some groups wondering how we
may be able to cooperate with corvids
one idea is to train crows and other
corvids to pick up cigarette butts or
garbage
a few different companies are developing
devices that will autonomously train the
birds giving them a treat once they
place the trash into the device
a theme park in france has already been
undertaking a similar operation
they trained six rooks to pick up trash
four days a week under the supervision
of the park's falconer
while it may seem like we're taking
advantage of these birds and their
intelligence by having them do something
we should already be doing ourselves
those involved seem to have good
intentions
it helps the environment teaches humans
to cooperate with another species
and teaches the public about these
intelligent creatures
by studying other intelligent species
and what made them that way
scientists have gained a better
understanding of the brain and its
development
and for all we know we could be
overlooking other small brained species
that could harbor a higher intelligence
other animals that can help us unlock
the many secrets of the brain
i love talking about animal intelligence
on this channel because i love the way
the brain works
i love its mysteries and its
unbelievable power and because of this i
love the feeling of learning of grasping
new concepts of those moments of sudden
understanding washing over you
when physics and math and chemistry and
biology start to click together feeling
like one beautiful interconnected
machine that explains our universe
and i'd like to think that crows feel
this too when they get their treat out
of the tube
and to engage myself in stem learning i
use brilliant
brilliant is an amazing tool for
learning stem interactively
the quizzes puzzles and downright
delightful animations make the learning
engaging where it almost feels like a
game
and if you get stuck on a particular
question brilliant doesn't penalize you
or impede your progress
instead they give you an in-depth
explanation to guide you to the right
answer so you can learn from your
mistakes it's easy to learn in this low
pressure environment and most
importantly it's easy to learn by doing
there are so many courses to dive into
from neural networks to algorithms to
logic and probability or my new favorite
scientific thinking
nature is a puzzle and in this course
you get to learn about principles of
physics and engineering by playing with
mechanics energy and light in a bunch of
interactive puzzles
to get started for free visit
brilliant.org
real science or click on the link in the
description and the first 200 people
will get 20 off brilliant's annual
premium subscription and if you're
looking for something else to watch
right now you can watch our previous
video about the jellyfish that lives
forever or watch real engineering's
latest video about the way engineering
solved the mystery of the concord crash